could you tell us some secrets and what
do you do to impress and surprise your
opponents um well I mean it's just small
small tweaks on known ideas uh or chess
wise chess wise other it's not like or
something the surprise your opponent one
thing that uh leaves for beating a
machine is just to pull out the plug
which is not to fear any uh legal things
after that uh yeah or you can just smash
smash it that all The
Works did you do it oh you don't play
computers at all uh no I mean I've uh
smashed the controller on my PlayStation
but not on uh what game was that uh no I
think it was just FIFA a few years ago I
actually did it several times like there
was a game shop uh uh nearby and and
there we go ah not you again I know what
you've done